Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David Hartz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy and here we go again it's like
having to prove that water is wet or
that Hillary Clinton is corrupt but
since Barack Obama has recently yet
again affirmed that Jihad terrorists are
twisting and hijacking the religion of
Peace once again it's necessary to prove
that that is not the case Obama is right
about one thing this question does
matter for what strategy the us and the
Free World should pursue against the
jihadis that's what makes his denial and
willful ignorance nothing short of
catastrophic CNN reported recently that
Obama said the question of whether or
not to use the term Islamic terrorist
was he said sort of manufactured as an
issue he claimed yet again that
terrorist organizations like Al-Qaeda or
isil as he calls it have perverted and
distorted and tried to claim the mantle
of Islam for an excuse for basically
barbarism and death warming to his point
Obama added these are people who've
killed children killed Muslims take sex
slaves there's no religious rationale
that would justify in any way any of the
things that they do is he right of
course not okay he said kill children
now a Hadith an authoritative report of
Muhammad's words and deeds said that
Muhammad when asked about the women and
children of the polytheists being killed
during the night raid said they are from
them now what does that mean they are
from them let's go to Sudanese Muslim
cleric Muhammad al- jazuli he commented
on this I was very happy to learn about
the relevant Hadith I felt Overjoyed
when I heard it musab IB Jana told the
prophet Muhammad that while the Muslims
would attack the polytheists at night
women and children would be harmed the
prophet Muhammad answered their
offspring constitute part of them that
is they are from them they are part of
them said our beloved Muhammad this is
not merely someone's opinion thus
killing their women and children is
permitted now if a Muslim cleric thinks
that is he a misunderstand of Islam
while Obama understands it correctly not
likely Obama also said that the Jihad
terrorists were not Islamic because they
killed Muslims but the Quran gives
permission for Muslims to be killed if
they are considered to have departed
from Islam it says this they but wish
that you should reject Faith as they do
and thus be on the same footing but do
not take friends from their rank until
they immigrate in the way of Allah that
is become Muslim but if they turn
Renegade seize them and kill them
wherever you find them that's Quran 4:89
to immigrate in the way of Allah would
involve their becoming Muslim but if
they turn Renegade after that that is
leave Islam then they are to be killed
the Quran also says the punishment of
those who make war against Allah and his
messenger and spread corruption in the
land shall be to put them to death or to
have them cruci CR ified or to have
their hands and feet cut off on
Alternate sides or to banish them from
the land that's
5:33 the Islamic State claims that that
is the C claims that it is the caliphate
the sole Authority that Muslims should
obey and that to oose it therefore
constitutes making war against Allah and
his messenger no exception is given in
this Quran verse or anywhere else
nowhere are Muslims who are considered
to have made war against Allah and his
messenger Exempted from this death
penalty Obama said the jihadis were not
Islamic because they take sex slaves yet
the seizure of infidel girls and their
use as sex slaves is sanctioned in the
Quran According to Islamic law Muslim
men can take captives of the right hand
the Quran says oh Prophet Lo we have
made lawful to you your wives to whom
you have paid their dowries and Those
whom your right hand possesses of Those
whom Allah has given you as Spoils of
War that's chap
33:50 CH 4:3 and chapter 4 vers 24
extend this privilege to Muslim men in
general the Quran says that a man may
have sex with his wives and with these
slave girls the Believers must win
through those who humble themselves in
their prayers who avoid vain talk who
are active in Deeds of Charity who
abstain from sex except with those
joined to them in the marriage bond or
whom their right hands possess for they
are free from blame that's Quran 23:
1-6 Obama also said But but what I have
been careful about when I describe these
issues is to make sure that we do not
lump these murderers into the billion
Muslims that exist around the world
calling them Islamic terrorists wouldn't
do that any more than referring to
American Senators means that all
Americans are Senators calling them what
they are simply opens the door for us to
understand what they're all about and
how best to counter them clinging
determinedly to his fantasies however
Obama added if you had an organization
that was going around killing and
blowing people up and said we're on the
Vanguard of Christianity as a Christian
I'm not going to let them claim my
religion and say you're killing for
Christ I would say that's ridiculous
sure but if this group was basing its
actions on some Twisted interpretation
of Christian scripture law enforcement
and intelligence officials would be
derelict in their duty if they didn't
study that interpretation even if they
understood it was wrong in order to
understand the motives and goals of the
enemy and develop effective ways to
defeat them yet that is exactly what
Obama has for forbidden on October 19th
2011 faran of Muslim Advocates wrote a
letter to John Brennan who was then the
homeland security Zar and is now of
course the head of the CIA the letter
was signed not just by Hera but by the
leaders of virtually all the significant
Islamic groups in the United States 57
Muslim Arab and South Asian
organizations many with ties to Hamas
and the Muslim Brotherhood including the
Council on American Islamic relations
the Islamic Society of North America the
Muslim American society the Islamic
circle of North America Islamic relief
USA and the Muslim public affairs
Council the letter denounced what it
characterized as US government agencies
use of biased false and highly offensive
training materials about Muslims and
Islam and demanded that all mention of
Islam and Jihad be removed from
counterterror training materials Brennan
immediately complied so since then it
has been Administration policy to ignore
and deny the motivating ideology of
jihad Terror now that's a recipe for
defeat and disaster you cannot defeat an
enemy you don't understand under Barack
Obama refusing to understand the enemy
is official US government policy I'm
Robert Spencer